hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that knows that translucent
doesn't mean invisible it means
semi-transparent so how about the boys
huh back in the late 2010s a time when
superheroes ruled the pop culture Roost
this Amazon TV series burst through the
wall and said no trust me you do not
want these guys to be real if you aren't
familiar the boys is a satirical series
that imagines what a world with
superheroes would really look like and
oh man is this show a bloody good time
in a lot of different ways and while
there are tons of smaller Heroes with
superpowers in this world the biggest
and most popular of them all team up
into a super group known as the seven
and these guys aren't the type of Heroes
that you'd expect now they're not boy
scouts or friendly neighborhood Warriors
they're corrupt they're self-serving and
they're dealing with real world problems
like addiction insecurity and egotism
killing most criminals in their
crosshairs as well as plenty of
Innocence along the way the world of
this series is incredible but today I
wanted to take a look at one very
specific hero the biggest and definitely
baddest one of them all homelander I'm
not just like the rest of you I'm
stronger I'm smarter I'm better I am
better homelander is basically this
world's version of all the oldest
superhero tropes he can fly he's super
strong and fast he's basically
invulnerable and he has himself heat
vision all while literally being wrapped
in an American flag and this is why
homelander caught the attention of my
theorist brain so quickly in this show
that leans so heavily on the realistic
consequences of superheroes got me
wondering just how super is this
superest of soups and by that I mean how
strong wrong is homelander given what we
see him do across the series what are
some real numbers to homelander power
and what would his biggest strength be
well loyal theorists here's the craziest
part the thing that I think is
homelander biggest strength definitely
isn't what you'd expect and I also think
it's his biggest weakness and knowing
what that is is going to tell us a lot
about where the story of the boys is
headed in future Seasons but before we
hop into the strength of this Mega
Corporation superhero let's talk about
the strength of our latest round of
theory wear the Northern Lights
Collection so it's just business t i
when Mr butcher in history has it ever
been about anything different right now
Stan because Theory Weare isn't just
regular old merch anymore it's not just
logos that were're slapping on t-shirts
to make a quick Buck these are actual
pieces of clothing that'll be useful to
you in your everyday life while looking
darn good wearing them the perfect
example of this has got to be our new
polar Embrace gloves which we designed
to be both waterproof and insulated so
your fingers can stay toasty on those
early morning commutes to work or school
but best of all these things have
touchscreen fingers letting you use your
your phone or tablet without having to
take them off that means you don't need
to give yourself frostbite every time
you rewind episodes of the boys to hear
their Wild on liners do you know what a
GPS is or Bluetooth or I mean the
internet you made those words up but of
course a pair of gloves is best
complemented with a nice cozy jacket and
thankfully for you we have a ton of
options available like the field watch
heavy fleece not only is this jacket
super heavyweight covered in a soft
fleece material but it's designed to
keep you cozy even in below freezing
temperatures bundle up in this bed boy
and feel like you have the power of heat
at your fingertips anywhere you go our
whole mission with the Northern Lights
Collection was to make winter clothing
that's going to make you feel warm and
cozy as the weather cools down we also
wanted these pieces to be able to live
on in your wardrobe for years to come
stay fashionable and useful long into
the future and I got to say I think
we've managed to do it so please go
check out the Northern Lights Collection
over at Theory wear.com but that's
enough Shameless self-promotion for now
let's get back to the boys shall we so
to figure out what homelanders most
powerful abilities are I figure that we
need to First decide which Powers we're
actually going to measure for today
purposes I've narrowed it down to the
three that I think are his most iconic
super strength how fast he can move and
heat vision so let's just look at the
science behind each of these and see
what we can dig up starting with
homelander super strength so far the
boys have really held back from showing
homelander undergoing the sorts of
Godlike fatza strength that we typically
see in other superhero shows he hasn't
lifted a car with one finger or stopped
a building from collapsing or held a
boat together with his bare hands or
anything like that now that's not to say
that he couldn't do things like that
when it's suggested that he save an
airplane full of passengers from
crashing in his reasons for not doing it
have nothing to do with a lack of
strength but rather a lack of things to
stand on lift the plane up lift the
plane how there's nothing to stand on
but if he were standing on Solid Ground
assuming it's at its maximum takeoff
load lifting this Boeing 737 means that
homelander could shoulder 430,000 lb or
about
195,000 kg no problem and if we want to
bring comic evidence into this that
version of homelander was able to grab
an F-16 fighter jet weighing roughly
20,000 lb or 9,2 kg with a single hand
and easily toss it across an airport
hanger in annoyance all that said we do
see other fatza of strength throughout
the show with homelander casually
throwing people around like it's nothing
physically punching through human bodies
crushing human skulls like a nut it is
all very violent and very gruesome and
very YouTube unfriendly so you're just
going to have to trust me on all this
just from these Feats of Strength alone
we can get an idea of how crazy powerful
homelander actually is one study stated
that crushing a human skull would
require up to 1,200 lb of force which
should be like putting your head inside
of a hydraulic press machine and this
was something that homelander did with a
single hand well distracted as for
punching through a human chest
unsurprisingly it's difficult to find
information about how much force you
need to break through the human sternum
with the human fist I wonder why that
might be hard to find go figure but you
know what we don't actually need those
numbers to calculate the wild strength
that homelander demonstrates in this one
scene as he pulls his fist out of this
guy much to his annoyance it's covered
in blood that means that his punch
actually broke through the skin which
takes a lot more Force for a blunt
object than you might expect it takes
roughly 100 lb per square in of pressure
to puncture through human skin and given
that a human fist is roughly 64 Square
in in surface area that means that
homelander needed to apply
6,400 PSI on this dude in order to get
his hand bloody an average boxer by
comparison can deliver between 12200 and
1700 PSI which is basically the same
level of pressure as an industrial
pressure washer now imagine that but
three times worse and it was nothing to
homelander and if you if you think
that's scary it's not even the most
strength that we see him using in the
very first scene of the show we see
homelander casually tossing a bank
robber away after saving two kids that
he was holding a gunpoint I was actually
able to figure out roughly where the
scene takes place thanks to the street
signs going through it frame by frame
you can see signs for bow rum place and
Smith Street real locations in Brooklyn
New York thankfully this means that
we're able to get a pretty good idea of
how far homelander through the thug
since a standard New York City Block is
about 264 ft by 900 ft or about 80 m x
274 using that I was able to estimate
that the robber was thrown about 135 ft
he was in the air for roughly 6.1
seconds and plugging all of that into a
projectile motion calculator will find
that he was thrown at about 68 mph 30.5
m a second assuming that this dude
weighed as much as an average American
male and plug in all of that into a
kinetic energy formula we'll find that
homelander threw this guy with a wild
42,000 Jews of energy to give you a
frame of reference that would be 26
times harder than boxing Legend Mike
Tyson can punch Okay so homelander
physical strength is incredible but that
doesn't matter a whole lot if he's not
fast enough to land a punch but don't
you worry my friends he is more than
fast enough to land a blow that'll rip
through someone's chest easily both on
foot and flying through the air
homelander is tremendously fast we see
this clearly demonstrated the multiple
times he catches up with planes
mid-flight but that is nowhere near
homelander most impressive feat of speed
nope that honor goes to this scene from
the finale of season 1 after confronting
boy leader Billy butcher in a house
that's been rigged with C4 explosives
but detonates them hoping to hurt
homelander and himself however
homelander is able to move quickly
enough not only to save himself from the
explosive blast but butcher as well c4's
velocity of detonation or the rate at
which it explodes is about 26,400 ft a
second that is 18,000 mph 29,000 km an
hour now you can obviously tell that
that is ludicrously fast but moving that
quickly also means that homelander would
be creating bone crunching amounts of
energy using the equation Force equals
mass time acceleration we can figure out
the that homelander is generating a
crazy
700,000 Newtons of force just from
moving now that might be nothing to
homelander but you got to remember he's
also moving butcher at this speed which
would almost certainly kill him cuz that
force is roughly 10 times worse than
what you'd feel during a 40 mph head-on
crash so in Saving butcher in the scene
homelander actually kind of killed him
which you know would save him a lot of
trouble further in the series well super
speed and physical strength are both
wildly powerful abilities the flashiest
of homelander superpowers and the one he
leans on the most is undoubtedly his
laser vision in fact he uses it so much
and it's such a big part of the show's
marketing that I'd classify this as his
signature ability but just how powerful
is it is it the strongest ability after
all we see him do everything from use it
to melt guns to cut through humans like
their butter so to calculate what I
figured would be the upper range of the
amount of energy homelander can output
through his eyes I decided to use this
scene where he cuts through a private
jet in just 96 seconds how' I figure it
out well it was a lot of complicated
math but here's the long and short of it
we were able to figure out that the
plane used in the scene was a British
Aeros space 125 and though we couldn't
find the exact materials this model of
plane is made from most commercial
aircraft are made using aluminum
titanium and steel we're just going to
be using aluminum to keep things simple
and to underestimate his power in this
case using the aerospace's height length
and Hull thickness we were able to
estimate that he was able to melt
roughly
115.7 kg of aluminum in that9 seconds
insane using the average width of a pair
of human eyes is the size of our laser
beams assuming that the hull is made of
aluminum and that the temperature of the
hull is about -40° Celsius or the warmer
end of the outside of an airplane at
cruising altitude with some back in the
napkin math we can calculate that
homelanders less than 1 second of heat
vision here transferred a massive 73
m529 180 jewles of energy directly to
the metal on that plane that is over 20
kwatt hours or a little less than what
you'd need to power an average house for
an entire day all from homelander just
looking at something really hard for
less than a second and believe it or not
all of these assumptions were actually
just lowballing the amount of energy
homelanders out putting in the scene we
were giving him the easiest possible
scenario here and it's also not saying
anything about his ability to control
the intensity of those IE beam he's able
to heat up a bottle of milk without
melting the bottle or boiling the liquid
that right there tells us that
homelander is just really good at
figuring out the thermodynamics of
objects around him knowing how much
energy his eye beams need to Output to
heat milk but also to melt aluminum
depending on the circumstance that is an
insane amount of control and probably a
stronger ability than just lifting
things or moving fast so it is clear
that Homeless Lander is just
ridiculously powerful but here's the
thing while his physical prowess is
unmatched I actually don't believe that
that's what makes homelander the most
powerful of superheroes instead
homelander biggest strength the thing
that makes him the most powerful and the
scariest of all the soups it's his brand
let me explain superheroes are big
business in the real world with the
corporations who own them bringing in
billions from those IP in 2013 alone the
most popular superheroes generated
between 275 million and 1.3 billion each
just from merchandise retail sales alone
own in a single year as the most
powerful soup in the world and the
leader of the seven between movies and
action figures and whatever homelanders
brand should easily be making at least
the lower end of that margin within the
world of the boys and that's not even
considering the military contracts that
homelander is able to bring in for the
vot company additionally it's very clear
that soups in this universe function
very similar to real world influencers
and they have way more power than you
might think first of all if we want to
continue the cash talk they can command
huge sums of money in multiple ways
popular athletes and YouTubers are often
worth tens or even hundreds of millions
of dollars multiple soccer players were
offered $1 billion contracts that they
turned down by the way because as one
article put it quote most soccer fans
around the world now follow players not
teams which makes a lot of sense when
you consider that two of these players
have between 100 and 480 million social
media followers that's in the same range
as the 193 million followers that
Starlight has in the world of the boys
over on Instagram and though she's
touted as the most followed soup
homelander has to have himself similar
numbers building off of that these
insane follower accounts give
influencers massive amounts of power oh
sure Mr Beast was able to leverage his
subscriber base to get Beast Burger into
the100 million Revenue range but what's
even more impressive was that he was
able to keep the feast table's chocolate
bar displays and retail stores clean
simply by asking fans to tidy them up
for him which they did all without pay
just because he asked them nicely and
it's not just their own stuff that these
influencers can push their followers
towards they are able to get their
followers to buy other people's stuff
too according to an Advertiser report
from precise TV and giraffe insights
almost half of teens remember seeing ads
on platforms like YouTube 60% consider
watching them instead of skipping the ad
and 70% have bought something that
they've seen Heck if you want to take
money out of this entirely 86% of Young
Americans want to become social media
influencers because they look up to
people like YouTubers and ticktockers
and this is definitely the way that
soups like homelander are treated in the
boys I mean just look at the interaction
that homelander has with the two kids
that he saves your boy okay can I get a
selfie of course you can this isn't the
way people react after being saved from
a bank robbery this is how people react
when meeting a celebrity they adore and
look up to but this doesn't even stop
there given all of this all the power
that homelanders acred through money and
cultural influence that's not even the
thing that gives him the most power
because he also has the full backing of
a multi-billion dollar conglomerate by
the end of season 3 of the boys
homelander takes control of vot
international installing Ashley Barrett
someone he considers a close Ally that
he can control as CEO in essence this
gives homelander CEO control of the
corporation that not only owns the legal
entity that is his brand but also most
other licensed superheroes throughout
the world and there is no overselling
just how much power or how many
resources this affords homelander in
2018 14 of the top 30 most powerful
people in the world ranked by Forbes
were Executives at conglomerates right
there alongside Leaders of World
superpowers and given the social media
marketing for the boys VA is using all
of its power to make sure homelanders
reputation is upheld he's got a
propaganda machine at his fingertips in
the coming months homelander will stand
trial for saving his son from a vicious
Starlight loving Thug an act of heroism
now somehow being branded a murder make
no mistake VA and its shareholders stand
fully behind homelander really at this
point there's only one place left for
homelander to go only one place that he
could get even stronger I believe that
next season homelander is going to run
for president of the United States now
if that sounds outlandish it shouldn't
this didn't happen in the comics but the
show's already diverged a lot from that
story so it's clearly doing its own
thing plus there's already an election
going on in the world of the boys and
think about how much time the show was
devoted to homelander caring so much
about where he sat with his base 21
points they loved your speech a massive
44% uptake with white males in the Rust
Belt this isn't talk that you see with
celebrities these are the concerns of a
politician and if you think it's
ridiculous that homelander the
influencer superhero could be leader of
the Free World remember someone who was
also an influencer and CEO who used that
to run a campaign that earned billions
of dollars in free advertising
eventually winning the White House in
the real world so sure homelander could
level cities with a look he could carry
airplanes on his shoulders he could
punch through a human body just by
walking at a Brisk Pace but none of that
compares to the power of influence and
here in lies our last little twist loyal
theorists because this greatest strength
is also going to be homelander biggest
weakness clearly there isn't a lot that
can actually hurt homelander we can
count the times he's been physically
beaten and actually injured on a single
hand those barely slowed him down but
while he has all the power and influence
and the love of millions it is built a
larger than life ego combined that with
his fragile state of mind the fact that
he craves all of that attention that
right there that's the way to take him
down you might not be able to physically
overpower and destroy homelander the man
but you can destroy homelander the brand
the idea the character and once you do
that the man implodes on himself but hey
it's all just a theory a film Theory and
cut